bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france d'abord est ce
que vous avez pu obtenir des
informations que vous avez pu joindre
quelqu'un au burkina façon c'est que les
liaisons elles sont compliquées pour
l'instant
écoutez la prestation d'information
actuellement c'est ce qu'on reçoit par
les réseaux sociaux il est par les
médias et il faut se prononcer avec
beaucoup de prudence parce que ce qu'on
sait c'est effectivement
l'arrestation du chef de l'état du
président ainsi que deux autres
personnalités politiques dont le premier
ministre d'après certaines sources mais
je pense que la situation est incertaine
depuis hier soir on a appris
effectivement qu'il y avait des tirs et
ce déploiement dans la ville notamment
au regard 2000 le quartier où se situe
la résidence du chef de l'état du
président est donc voilà où on en est on
c'est une situation ouverte volatile on
en sait davantage bien sûr sur les
facteurs qui ont provoqué cette crise
politico-militaire et tout ce qu'on peut
souhaiter c'est que contrairement aux
crises politico militaires sanglantes
qui ont ponctué l'histoire du pays que
cette fois ci pas un cheveu pas une
goutte de sang la citoyenne burkina
venez soit
versé alors c'est que le pays il est
habitué aux mutineries
est-ce qu'on stade actuel on pensait que
l'on peut parler de coup d'état
peut-être
tentative de coup d'état ce qui est sûr
il me tient mairie puisque on a eu hier
soir effectivement
apparemment dans l'ouest de la ville au
camp sangoulé lamizana
qu'en général baba sy il y a eu 7 ces
tirs de sommation puis effectivement
l'épisode de l'arrestation ccd symptômes
de processus de coup d'état mais à
partir du moment où il n'y a aucune
déclaration je pense qu'il faut se
garder déjà de d'avaliser cette thèse du
coup même s'il ya des symptômes des
indices qui convergent ce sens alors le
président à christian roch kaboré aurait
donc été arrêtées seraient thomas de
soldats mutins quels sont les scénarii
possibles
est ce qu'il ya des discussions en cours
votre avis des négociations
écoutez je pense qu'il faut faire la
genèse de cette crise politico-militaire
ya il ya trois facteurs à mon avis
d'abord il ya les sécurités vous savez
que le burkina a perdu au moins 2000
citoyens depuis peut-être la crise
l'attentât du cappuccino 15 janvier 2016
sur l'avenue kwamé n'krumah 2000 ça fait
un citoyen burkinabè tuer tous les une
fois par jour il y a aussi un sentiment
d'impuissance face à l'impunité
dire du côté des civils on a vu des
massacres notamment à bayrou l'irgoun
solane
récemment au niveau des choses militaire
à hinata je crois que c'est un
mi-novembre 2021 donc il ya ce sentiment
d'impunité doublé par un sentiment
d'impuissance et le troisième facteur
c'est on lui faut dire peut-être
l'inspiration du modèle malien où on a
vu une convergence entre peuples eux
éliminés entre un peuple indignés et des
jeunes officiers patriotes qui ont aussi
le ras le bol de ne n'avoir pas les
moyens les ressources pour faire face au
terrorisme
parce que la vraie question aujourd'hui
c'est la lutte contre le terrorisme et
la possibilité d'assurer la sécurité du
citoyen le droit à la vie des citoyens
donc
aujourd'hui est ce que les militaires
bon s'ils obtiennent ce qu'ils ont
souhaité ce qu'ils ont exprimé hier
c'est à dire les changements au niveau
des dirigeants
un militaire la libération peut-être de
l'officier qui a été arrêté il ya
quelques jours est-ce qu'ils vont donc
retourné à la caserne avec peut-être une
accélération de la mise en place de ce
nouveau paradigme dont parlait le
président encore kaboré quand il a il a
remanié son gouvernement il a parlé d'un
nouveau paradigme est ce que ici l'armée
va accélérer la mise en place de ce
nouveau paradigme ou bien est-ce qu'elle
va vouloir prendre directement les
commandes pour impulser une nouvelle
dimension de la lutte contre le
terrorisme et la sécurité au burkina
faso balle je peux rien vous dire je
pense que les heures et les jours qui
viennent bon nous donner la réponse on
les membres de la cedeao la communauté
des états d'afrique de l'ouest se disent
inquiets dans un communiqué juste à
l'instant il ya vous évoquez là l'échec
d'une politique sécuritaire de la part
du président qui aurait donc été arrêtés
ce qui peut y avoir aussi des pressions
à l'intérieur même de 2,7 armées
burkinabè dans l'entourage en tout cas
dans selon des proches de l'entourage
présidentiel avec qui j'ai pu
communiquer on évoque la libération par
exemple du du général john derek est un
proche de l'ex président déchu blaise
compaore qui vit en exil
est-ce que vous pensez que il peut y
avoir une influence
dépression justement venus de
l'extérieur
écoutez c'est certain que
le burkina faso et est pris dans une
série de défiance il y a nous avons la
plus grande frontière avec le mali donc
déjà un terreau militaire c'est nous
sommes ouvrira sur le mali nous sommes
divers ouvert culturellement sur le mali
donc certaines branches de l'armée
peuvent regarder du côté de malley pour
des raisons objectives mais aussi de
nous sommes aussi nous avions nous avons
une forte communauté une relation
historique avec la côte d'ivoire
et que le monde connaît le l'orientation
politique et idéologique du régime en
place en côte d'ivoire donc je pense que
ça ce sont des contradictions dans
lesquelles le président du faso du
burkina faso a été prise vous savez
quand on regarde ta le soutien justement
du pouvoir ivoirien vous faites allusion
un soutien à l'ex président blaise
compaore
écouter le président blaise compaoré et
en côte d'ivoire il a été filtrée
pour le général je n'ai pas
d'information précise mais c'est la même
formation famille politique donc avec
une sympathie au moins un minimum un
minimum
de la côte d'ivoire qui est que le grand
acteur politique francophone en afrique
de l'ouest et je pense que le burkina
est tiraillé aussi entre ses aspirations
de la jeunesse
révoltée peut être révolutionnaire en
afrique l'afrique de l'ouest aujourd'hui
et des forces anciennes qui sont là je
voulais dire que quand on regarde la
décision qui a été prise le 9 janvier
belle unité 2022 par la cedeao je
regardais l'image la photo de famille à
la sortie de ce sommet de la cedeao et
il ya quelque chose d'assez paradoxal on
voit le président kaboré dans son face
aux dents fanis à 10h07 ce costume
panafricain ouest africains qui évoque
effectivement khroma modibo kéita et
cetera et quand on dit le communiqué
qu'il a signé un communiqué totalement
vengeurs contre un peuple indigné un
peuple frère qui s'élevait le peuple du
mali je pense que c'est ça la
contradiction à la tête de ce régime est
ce que maintenant avec ce coup de chaud
il va pouvoir continuer basculer vers
les aspirations plus populaire plus
progressistes ou est ce que les
syndicats des chefs d'état de l'afrique
de l'ouest pas réussi à infléchir la
situation pour maintenir le statu quo je
ne saurais vous le dire mais je pense
que ce sont des contradictions très
fortes auxquelles est confronté
aujourd'hui le burkina lui merci
beaucoup à vous lazare était zerbo
d'avoir répondu à nos questions en
direct je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur de philosophie